the solar farm at Broken Hill is a 52
megawatt project it is the second
largest project in Australia and one of
the largest projects in the southern
hemisphere it took about 9 to 12 months
and construct and has a project value
quli with the ningún project of 450
million dollars Broken Hill obviously
has a long and storied history
associated with mining as a function of
what's been happening in that industry
obviously there's been a paring down in
job opportunities in community growth
and so this was a fantastic opportunity
for Broken Hill to really embrace a new
industry and what we think is a really
new and exciting source of job creation
the broken your project had about
hundreds of 200 jobs created during
construction period now as that
construction winds down the operational
presence will be much less since the
change in leadership at the federal
government level we've started to see a
very proactive reach out from another of
the agencies that previously weren't as
well supported if you look at all the
factors you need for large-scale solar
deployment Australia is probably number
2 on the list globally there are so many
obvious reasons why large-scale solar
should be contributing it's really just
been a function of policy constraints
policy uncertainty which we're now
starting to see some clarity around and
so we're confident with the right policy
signals with the right private sector
commitment that we're now seeing
large-scale soil will be off to the
races in Australia